this week on brian ross investigates
calls for a federal investigation after
the release of this video
a suspect in a mississippi county jail
held down with a knee to his neck
for some three and a half minutes he's
bleeding from his mouth
he's got sleep from his leg and
until i have a vision
the death of robert loggins was declared
an accident by local authorities
but dr michael baden says otherwise the
manner of death is properly homicide
we'll talk with the veteran mississippi
investigative reporter jerry mitchell
who broke the story
the way in which he's dealt with just
the humanity of it i mean they didn't
even pull this pants
plus are you selling voices
new developments in the case of the
self-proclaimed archbishop
who sold industrial bleach as a miracle
cure
for autism heart disease cancer and even
covet 19.
i've got the facts you people are liars
mark grenon now facing criminal charges
brought by a federal grand jury in
florida
even as he claims the sale of his
miracle cure
is protected by the freedom of religion
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of media height i mean
there's nothing here i mean yes
we have native americans but but
candidly that that
there isn't much native american culture
in american culture
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague ronda schwartz and rhonda we
begin with calls for a federal
investigation
following the release of a new video
that you're about to see
which shows yet another person ending up
dead in police custody
after being put through the technique of
a knee to the neck
the same technique that a jury in
minneapolis found killed george floyd
rhonda
brian this case took place in
mississippi involving a man by the name
of robert loggins
it happened almost three years ago but
has been kept quiet by authorities who
called it an accident
until the mississippi center for
investigative reporting
whose board i am on discovered this
disturbing video wait for this over
i will fly in the sky
i'll show them all robert loggins was
already in bad shape
but very much alive when officers
brought him to the county jail
in grenada mississippi the 26 year old
logans had been taken into custody a
short while earlier
around 5 30 in the morning 9-1-1 where's
your emergency
calling for help responding to a call
about a stranger in a backyard
police reports indicate officers used a
taser on him
at least eight times as he resisted
arrest
take your hand
take your hand and one officer
hit him in the head with a flashlight oh
but his treatment got worse at the
county jail
the jail surveillance video shows
loggins being carried in
handcuffed his pants left at his ankles
a few minutes later five officers pile
on top of loggins
after he apparently resisted efforts to
put a second set of handcuffs on him
one officer appears to put his knee to
logan's neck
this lasts about three and a half
minutes when the officers finally get
off him
his body appears limp the supervisory
sergeant
calls dispatch he's bleeding from his
mouth
he's got uh he's bleeding from his leg
until
some six minutes later the supervisory
sergeant finally
checked loggins for his pulse there was
none
sheriff's pharma i need an analyst at
the grenada county jail now i got an
unresponsive uh
offender he was just brought in here by
the y'all the
uh mr merriman and two other officers
this man has got
no heartbeat and he's not breathing i
want them
officers back over here and i want
ambulance here this is sergeant clark
get him here now it took another three
minutes for the emt
crew to arrive efforts to revive robert
loggins were too late
the state pathologist ruled his death an
accident
saying it was due to methamphetamine
toxicity
we're joined now by jerry mitchell of
the mississippi center for investigative
reporting which first broke the story
jerry thanks so much for joining us what
are we seeing on that
tape with mr loggins as he's brought
into the jail and they're getting on top
of him
what's happening what triggered that
moment he seemed kind of out of it
he uh had supposedly been doing some
meth and he also had some mental issues
so when they were talking to him he was
spouting off scripture and talking in
tongues and
you know things like that i mean you
know things that that indicate he wasn't
necessarily all there
and um and so they brought him in
and and apparently the resting officer
wanted his handcuffs
back so literally these officers just
pile on top of him
in order to switch these handcuffs and
they're literally on top of him for
about three and a half minutes
and then when they get off of him just
no movement at all brian i mean
just nothing the guy doesn't move at all
and
and as you've reported before about this
positional affixia
uh you know if you just
just the act alone of handcuffing
someone behind the back
and leave them on their stomach can that
alone can cause
issues in terms of people being able to
breathe and then when you
add weight to the back it increases that
risk even more
of people not being able to to breathe
so this is very much exactly what
happened to george floyd
absolutely absolutely it's the same kind
of thing and you see the one
officer who actually looks like he's
kneeling uh
on the neck uh as well so you see
almost identical to kind of some of the
things we saw in george floyd case
mitchell asked renowned forensic
pathologist dr michael baden to review
the case
i shared the autopsy with dr michael
baden
and he said look this is a homicide this
isn't an
accident you can tell by the video that
you know this wasn't an accident
in my opinion the the true manner of
death is restraint asphyxia
in inability to breathe due to the
pressure that was being put on his back
during restraint
and the manner of death is properly
homicide
homicide meaning that death at the hands
of another
the the amount of drug taken that by him
was enough to cause bizarre behavior
and inability to understand what the
police were asking him to do
and respond appropriately but not enough
to cause death a very low level for
causing death
the other thing i might note is the
state pathologist
files if you go by what he had in the
files
he didn't have a copy of this video so
my suspicion is he may have never seen
this video
before he made the ruling that this was
an accident
the incident happened some two and a
half years ago and only became public
after jerry mitchell was able to get a
hold of the video from the jail
well i would say i had a source
basically
leak it to me and it's obv it's never
been out there before so it's never been
made public
until we made it public and so it's just
not been
seen it wasn't like authorities released
this video or showed this video
it was not even seen and i had a source
leak it to me
and now there's litigation going on his
family is in fact
suing the police office the
emails people responding for the
ambulance and otherwise
and what about uh local authorities is
there any indication they plan to
prosecute the officers
no none and in fact from best indication
that no one got
suspended or you know any kind of
discipline that we can tell
so and certainly no charges at this
point i know
that um they questioned you know the
officers involved of course they all
insisted they had done nothing wrong
logan's family has now filed a civil
suit against the police who mitchell
says
knew loggins from previous encounters
even called him by his family nickname
rah-rah and they even though they knew
him even though his nickname
uh they just you know obviously you can
see from the tape
the way in which he's dealt with just
the humanity of it i mean they didn't
even pull up his pants brian i mean like
he had his
pants around his ankles and didn't even
pull up his pants and
you know different things like that that
you would you would hope people would do
uh to be more humane a callous
disregard really isn't it jerry it's sad
story it really is brilliant
all right jerry mitchell from the
mississippi center for investigative
reporting
thank you so much for being with us
tonight thank you brian
the mississippi black legislative caucus
has now called for a federal
investigation into what happened to
robert loggins
our request for comment from the
mississippi police department the
granada police department went
unanswered
coming up next a crackdown finally on
the man who calls himself an
archbishop and has made a fortune by
selling industrial
bleach as a cure for autism cancer even
covent 19.
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
a federal grand jury has now indicted an
alleged con man who i've been tracking
for years
as he made a fortune selling what he
called a miracle cure for autism
cancer and lately clovid19 it turns out
the miracle cure is nothing other than
industrial bleach which tens of
thousands of desperate americans
use for themselves or gave to their
children
authorities say mark grenon has made
more than a million dollars
offering a miracle cure for autism heart
disease
cancer and other serious medical
ailments
but the magic cure was nothing more that
industrial bleach
according to the new federal indictment
federal authorities raided the family
home in florida last year
where he and his three sons allegedly
packaged their miracle cure
in a backyard shed grenin calls himself
the archbishop of his own church
and said last year he has the right to
ignore the fda
and sell his miracle cure as a religious
sacrament
so we just basically said no we have the
first to write
first amendment which is i was it's
right up here
i don't know if you could see it too
good but it's right up there
it says we have the exercise the free
exercise
our religious beliefs but grenlin hardly
seemed a man of god
when i tried to question him several
years ago about his claims
for the miracle cure are you harming
people do you think of this sir no
you're not not at all and you stand by
that this can cure
all these diseases and you honestly
believe this can cure cancer
you're an actor okay i'm a reporter a
piece of
they say in spanish but just just just
leave go check out the facts
okay service i've asked for live
interviews
yes i've got the facts you people are
liars
the alleged archbishop mark grenon we're
joined now from west cork ireland by
fiona o'leary
the mother of an autistic child and who
has been combating
mark grenon and his miracle cure for
years
mrs larry thank you so much for being
here this must be good news but he
continues to operate
even under indictment yeah it's great
news uh brian but it's taken a long time
to get to this point
i've been campaigning against this
bleach for eight years now and um
you know it's not the it's not the end
of the bleach cult so to speak there are
many other people out there that are
giving this bleach to vulnerable people
including covert 19 patients especially
in latin america
we have colleagues of greenland's like
andreas calper who have formed a new
group called commusav
and they are giving this to thousands of
people in latin america as
a preventative for covert and as a
treatment that people are dying
including children
and they're actually giving this bleach
to children and a thought that it would
cure autism
people believe that you know well
there are many people that do and it's
very sad but it's a
reality for me as a mother to autistic
children that there are many quite
treatments out there for autism and this
month
april is autism awareness month so it's
a very important development in our
campaign to protect autistic children
that we see the greenhouse charged with
these serious charges
last weekend
miss o'leary a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
you mentioned that now people believe
it's going to cure kovac 19
what is it that makes people want to
take this stuff what it
how what makes them believe in this
well i think it's a lot to do with
politics and with what trump
said last year that maybe a disinfectant
could you know
cure covet or treat covid and it was
that comment that really ignited this
whole
nightmare which is what i can only say
it is
especially in poor countries like in
latin america
in argentina in bolivia they are
actually rolling this out as
a medicine for coded and it's been given
to people for free
and i've seen images of children mothers
elderly people lining up for their
bleach
shots to take not just to cure covered
but as a preventative they're using it
like a vaccine there
and people are dying and even a
five-year-old child died
in argentina last year from drinking
this bleach it's appalling
and the american authorities need to
step up and help people in latin
american countries right now
ernest o'leary as you know he's been
doing this for more than a decade
it took finally the revelations about
covet 19 to bring the crack down
why did it take so long for u.s
authorities to finally try to
put him out of business i don't know and
i suppose you know
as a lot of autistic children um i'm
very annoyed
that you know that this was known to the
authorities for a long long time
but i'm very grateful now and i think
covert is terrible to say as far as
silver lining to our campaign work
um we need to shut down the platforms
the big problem we have i suppose our
social media platforms like telegram
which is probably the worst platform now
that has just countless bleach groups
the images are shocking they're you know
images of children being abused
elderly people are getting this bleached
by iv
so in latin american countries communist
and andres calker
are actually injecting this into
people's veins so there are people with
covert having bleach pumped into their
bodies
and there's a lot of doctors that are
joining
this this scam now and it looks more
plausible so these poor people think
drinking bleach is um okay and many of
them are dying in fact
reports in hospitals in um argentina
show that 80 percent of people that die
in hospital for cover have ingested this
bleach product
so it's killing people and um we need to
start we
need to stop all of them it's not enough
just to um deal with the granules
they're part of a very bigger problem
now like
carrie rivera you know she's the one
that coined this bleach for autism
she hasn't been charged and andres
calvert there are two names i want to
put out there as the worst
at the moment right so much more to come
a funeral larry thank you so much for
being with us tonight
very much when we come back this week's
winners and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who
is the editor-in-chief of mediaite which
like the law and crime trial network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
and then we begin with your winner john
roberts at fox news who
got the assignment to walk back a rather
outrageous piece of information
that fox was spreading about joe biden
and banning beef
on friday we told you about a study from
the university of michigan to give some
perspective on president biden's
ambitious climate change goals that
research from 2020
found that cutting back how much red
meat people eat would have a drastic
impact on harmful greenhouse gas
emissions the data was accurate but a
graphic and a script
incorrectly implied that it was part of
biden's plan for dealing with climate
change
that is not the case
so that's a correction do you think
aiden or just a fact check
uh you know it's being presented as a
correction uh john roberts
i i would say provided sort of a gentle
fact check there
um bear in mind it was aired on john
roberts show the show that he anchors
it was also aired on a number of other
fox news shows
and the origins of this story which is
entirely invented
is a daily mail report the british
tabloid
which took a study from the university
of michigan from
last year before joe biden was even
president and it said that if you if
every american cut their meat red meat
consumption by a certain amount
we could cut carbon emissions by a
certain amount uh in 2020 2030.
um now it didn't the study didn't
mention biden at all
um but the daily mail report tied this
study
to biden and presented as if it was part
of biden's pledge
to cut a mission um so it was pretty
much invented there is no biden
call to reduce americans red meat
consumption but this daily mail report
was
the source that fox news used to present
a series of segments
on its airwaves claiming that biden was
doing this crackdown
on american red meat consumption it was
entirely made up
and john roberts to his credit issued a
central fact check there and a
correction
to his own reporting on it it would be
nice to see other fox news shows
that promoted this uh basically fake
news to also issue corrections
uh they have yet to do so
and not expected to do so either let's
so they were losers but winners because
at least john roberts acknowledged the
mistake
let's move on to the narrow the loser
that you've chosen
cnn analyst rick santorum talking about
the contributions or lack thereof
of native americans we birthed a nation
from nothing i mean there's nothing here
i mean yes we have native americans but
but candidly that that there isn't much
native american culture in american
culture
native american groups aiden have called
on cnn to get rid of santorum
he is a loser in this case isn't he
right
i mean i don't have to explain why that
comment is kind of insane
um saying that there was nothing here
when uh colonizers arrived in
the united in america um and that uh
native american history does not uh play
into american culture
um you know it's this is not that big a
deal for rick santorum uh he is on
the uh he's an advisor to a group a
political group founded by
mike pence um so he's not going to see
too many repercussions in that side
of his career um but he is a senior
political analyst for cnn
um and cnn takes these kind of things
seriously now there was a huge backlash
to these comments rick santorum
other cable news hosts like joy reid
called the comments
racist um and a number of cnn
personalities who had been fired for far
less offensive comments
uh like reza aslan and mark lamont hill
uh pointed out that uh
they they were fired far left uh and now
you have uh
the president of the national congress
of american indians
uh who called the comments uh racist
called rick santorum unhinged
and said he disgraced the cnn and said
the network should fire him so far
sienna's not commenting on them
so your comments actually are the real
antidote to this aren't they
to uh shame him publicly but perhaps not
fire him
yeah i think you know cnn's gonna gonna
weather this i think i doubt they're
gonna fire him as a political analyst
but they've been more receptive to
public outcries than
say fox news um which tends to stand up
to
uh you know advertiser boycotts and sort
of the social media outrage
um but so far uh cnn uh got requested a
comment and they issued a comment on
behalf of rick santorum
uh sort of a one-line comment trying to
explain away what he was what he meant
um but it doesn't sound like they're
going to be taking action with him he'll
probably just hear from there for a
little while
all right hayden mclaughlin thank you
much and thanks all of you for joining
us here on brian ross investigates
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you